One phenomenon that's somewhere between a light and a camera effect is fog. In
the real world, the atmosphere can absorb and reflect light in many different
ways. 3JS has two simple forms of fog. One is called linear fog and we've been
using that in a number of demos. A minimum distance is specified for where the
fog starts and the maximum for where the scene is entirely fog-colored.
Anything in between these two distances gets the fog-color blended in. The
other type of fog is exponential. This is a bit more like real life in that you
specify a density particles. This value effects how the fog increases somewhat
realistically. Both kinds of fog are useful in limiting how far we can see into
the distance. There's only so much content a program can load and without other
clever tricks the user will see the limits of the world. There are plenty of
other types fog and atmospheric effects possible. This demo shows what are
called god rays, a beams of light type of effect. See the additional course
materials for more about this particular effect, which uses post processing
image based shaders. To finish up, try out the fog demo that follows. You can
choose from among the different types of fog and change the related parameters
and fog color.